hey conan o'brien here and i'd like to
specifically talk
right now to the great state of arizona
listen up zonins put down those crystals
and stop staring into the majestic grand
canyon because i have a message for you
there's an election this november
so make sure you're registered to vote
now i know arizona is so excited that
you
might not have even heard the election
being so busy with your bolo ties and
your
teal arch mcdonald's but it's time to
make your voice heard somewhere besides
an epic asu vs u of a football game
and yes i know it's hard to find time to
register between
partying on houseboats exporting
precious natural resources like copper
turquoise and emma stone taking care of
three gorgeous national parks
explaining but it's a dry heat to
everyone that visits and challenging
tumbleweeds to duels
but it's still important to our
democracy plus you're the only state
that didn't fall for
the scam that is daylight savings which
means the people of arizona aren't
fools like the rest of us so arizona
make sure you're registered the deadline
for voter registration is october
5th go to when we all vote dot org it's
easy
take all that positive sedona vortex
energy and let it carry your spirit
to the poles trust me arizona the only
thing more delicious than your
sonoran style hot dogs is the sweet
taste of democracy